so I was thinking about a previous
episode the one about movie genres and
music genres and how they differ from
one another when I started wondering
what are some other narrative techniques
that we can look at applying across
media for example montage was
conceptualized principally as a visual
technique and the modern use of it is
rooted principally in characters doing
something very process-oriented the idea
of audio montage is not unheard of but
it's usually relegated to the realms of
documentary such as a montage of
responses or radio play where it tries
to mimic the filmic process with audio
merely referencing and evoke the
Associated visuals so what would
narrative montage look like in song and
how would it change the way that the
story is told well I think it would look
a little something like Tegan and Sara's
the con some continue of this you should
know this I broke down the road shoot
back before you had a chance to forget
forgotten I am moving passes giving
notice I have to go yes I know the
feeling no you're leaving I find this to
be a fun example because it's not simply
a conceptual example of lyrical montage
but it marries it with a distinctly
lyrical strength the audience's
tolerance for abstraction the narrator
runs rapid-fire through the up and down
emotional cycle of a drawn-out toxic
painful breakup it's an entire story you
vocht simply by what the people involved
are willing to do it's a relationship
that's reached a point where they're
spying on each other and desperate
enough to believe that confessing to
various preaches of trust will somehow
mend the gap there's the angry
ultimatums sent out over email then
followed up with a desperate apology
before the other person has even had a
chance to respond the first first
seemingly ends with acceptance before
slamming right back into recidivism with
the hook with a phone call that is
clearly not mutual the lyrics aren't
just statements they're scenes
arranged in an order where each builds
on the next like montage evoked through
the acceptable abstraction lyrics are
fascinating in this way unlike film
where most content is considered literal
first and metaphorical second lyrics are
typically metaphor first and literality
second and this is ordinary wordplay
double entendre puns these are the
things that even turned out corporate
pop music or made
let me put it this way Katy Perry is not
interested in seeing your menagerie of
exotic poultry I wanna see you
peacock-cock-cock your pick up
continuing with the con as an example
two phrases are repeated through the
song both having a dual meaning the
first is I'm coming around which in the
substracted montage is used both as a
stalkerish threat meaning I'm coming by
your place please please please please
please take me back and as a concession
to moving on meaning I'm seeing your
point of view I'm coming around to your
way of thinking about things the second
coming towards the end of the song
encircle me I need to be taken down also
doubles up as a sympathetic plea and a
threat hug me I'm really wound up and I
need someone to love me surround me I'm
dangerous and I need to be stopped these
double meanings and the title of the
song itself come together to tell a
story about a disintegrating
relationship that is not merely toxic
but toxic and the narrator knows it the
pleas for reconciliation are a con it's
a bad idea it's a terrible idea it's
good for no one involved and everyone is
being robbed of time energy and sanity
as a result it's a story told entirely
through snippets lines that imply a
scene that's strung together imply a
full narrative it's abstracted very
broadly and it's left to the audience to
fill in the unspoken but mutually
understood details so something to think
about
how does exposure to one narrative
language impact our understanding of
other narrative languages definitely a
subject that will be coming back to in
the future but for now go in peace my
children in the name of like share and
subscribe
amen